pour vous marichou par exemple qui est
en face de vous je vous ai raconté son
histoire Mariko c'est une femme pour
vous ou non pour moi Mariko c'est un
homme c'est un homme transféminin c'est
à dire que c'est une personne qui est
biologiquement un mâle on peut pas dire
le contraire sauf que cette personne a
ben effectivement enfin à des goûts en
fait qui correspondent à ce qu'on
appelle le genre femme pour moi en fait
le genre est défini par des stéréotypes
malheureusement alors c'est vrai que
d'ailleurs la direction de France 2
paraît a tapé sur les doigts via salami
à la suite de cette séquence et j'ai vu
sur Twitter il y a beaucoup de gens qui
disent ah bah maintenant sur quelle
époque ils font du TPMP fondu Hanouna
après c'est vrai nous on débat comme ça
on le ferait mais là c'est vrai que là
c'est comme ça là c'est vrai que bon
voilà là j'étais comme sur la phrase de
Charline j'ai j'ai piqué mais Gérald et
Géraldine je sais que je vous aime oui
mais c'était extrêmement frontal mais je
ne comprends même pas qu'on donne la
parole sur le service public qui plus
est à quelqu'un qui vient déballer sa
haine des transgenres comme ça en fait
il y a même pas de débat on s'en fout de
ce que vous êtes un homme que vous êtes
une femme laissez les gens être comme
ils sont et si vous voulez comprenez pas
essayez de les comprendre de lui les
agresser et là c'était une agression
frontale la pauvre elle s'est fait
humiliée et c'est vrai que c'est
choquant que le service public diffuse
ce genre de débat qui pour moi n'avait
aucun sens n'avait pas sa place
enregistré il y avait les conseils de
programme pendant que c'était pas en
direct ils n'ont pas les grands-pères et
là effectivement ça me semble que le
public c'est encore une fois un débat ça
sa place mais là c'était pas un débat
c'était voilà une personne qui était
faite de haine et qui nous déversait sa
haine dans une mission enregistrée il y
a personne pour contredire ici bon là
ici c'est vrai qu'on nous on nous dit
souvent vous invitez tout le monde oui
mais ici il y a des grosses
contradictions et c'est vrai que voilà
ça ça secoue un peu moi j'ai pas entendu
madame c'est un délire que la
transphobie est un délit c'est pas une
c'est pas une c'est pas une opinion
c'est un délice juste cette phrase
merci en tout cas d'avoir un mini
chargée de l'égalité homme-femme a
réagir a dit que ça n'avait pas lieu
d'être et c'était inadmissible donc ça
c'est très bien ça prouve le
mécontentement quand même service public
gouvernement et effectivement moi je
suis d'accord avec Guillaume je n'ai pas
compris cette séquence qui plus est
enregistrée donc il faut la couper et
inadmissible que ça passe ça ne doit pas
être diffusé
de programme
ce sont des gens qui sont les bras
droits des directeurs de programme et
qui viennent dans les qui sont dans les
coulisses et qui regardent l'émission
nous c'est très bien mais ils sont là
ils ont des bonbons
exceptionnel mais mais voilà
effectivement je monte pas
il y en a des très bons mais euh
on a le droit d'en parler à une heure du
matin public